she has lived in new orleans for about
five years now
and she loves the european cheese plates
there so please welcome danielle
i am so so happy to be here um
huge fan of the r conferences especially
the arts like jared mentioned and the
twitter battles
um i'm
really
honored to be able to speak and i really
wish that we could have been together in
person but
i am a native new yorker and i am there
in spirit
so what i'm gonna tell you about
is
my blog um and how
i write my tutorials and i'm hoping that
it can inspire you to create your own
tutorials
and um
you know go from there i've done a lot
of talks on
why writing is necessary for programmers
it's something that we don't often think
about and aren't even really taught in
school
so i just wanted to share that with you
so this is my site that you see right
now um i'm gonna take you through
i'm going to show you this first
um so this is
a tutorial i did really recently in the
airport i do them a lot on the go um and
it was interesting because the way that
i
created this one
was i was bored i was bored in the
airport i didn't have headphones and i
thought well you know if i can't watch
through crime shows right now
i guess i will look up a crime data
package in r and see if there is one and
so that's my first um
lesson really is that there's a package
in r for everything you like if you have
some kind of random interest that pops
into your head um whether it's karaoke
singing or crime
or
even
just
i don't know traveling really um city
data social media
there's always a package that you can
explore and there are a lot of existing
tutorials out there that you can
adapt or you know adjust to your own
style so in this case um this package is
uh
it's just you know
it was created by um
matthew ashby and i found his tutorial
and then i just plugged i plugged myself
into art and i
um
did the whole work myself and so that's
a way to keep yourself genuine is
you know kind of be chatty in between um
talk about
or experience working out um the
visualizations and everything so that
you're not stepping on anyone's toes
you're not being redundant but you're
still um giving out the same information
the reason i do this is because
i
used a lot of written tutorials when i
was learning r um i was working at the
new orleans police department and i was
really trying to brush up on art in
between my years of mba and so
i thought you know it was really
convenient to be able to look at written
tutorials and see different options for
the same package because i couldn't
exactly watch videos at a workspace
which i'm sure you relate to and when
i'm home i don't really want to pause my
shows i just want to keep working and
have the tv on
um
so
i think that
it's really it's really hard when you
only have four or five um
resources so i just wanted to give back
to the art community and add more
resources
um
my second point goes to another tutorial
that i made
um
i have
a background in financial training and
that's why
i ended up doing my mba at tulane and
moving to new orleans as
jared mentioned earlier so
i
decided to
delve into just a package about trading
because that's something i already do on
e-trade and i just thought it would be
interesting to see how r could factor
into that
um and so
this is something i love i love looking
at candlestick charts so i wanted to
replicate my own it wasn't very
complicated that's something i also want
to tell you it's okay to start out with
just a few lines of code and explain you
know a few commands um that's what i do
often times i will say
okay now this is maybe three things you
can do with this package and i will come
back later
and
teach you the rest or you can ask me
about the rest um
that definitely makes it less
overwhelming for people and it makes it
less overwhelming to write um and
especially like what's really cool is
you can link back to other packages that
you wrote about um like there are two
really big financial packages that i've
explored quant mod and tidy quant and
then you can you know you just have more
options for content to talk about them
both and compare them
um
and then sometimes this is just like
my favorite one um
where
i was hungry and i
pulled up a picture of pasta because the
package that i was working with is
called data pasta it has nothing to do
with pasta it's just that i um
i
just wanted a picture of tortellini um
this this one was my favorite one
because
it definitely took a bunch of
packages to
um
start and so i
had a lot more steps in this one
but i felt that
it was a really good thing for people to
know because the whole thing is you can
cut and paste tables from any site you
want and then start playing with it in r
which is something i'd really wish that
i knew about in grad school um
so
i just want to
sum up and start summing up so that i
run out of time so i don't run out of
time um
i think the most important thing if you
want to start writing tutorials or if
even if you already do
you should think about the tutorials
that you liked when you were first
learning so for me
i really loved looking at database
tutorials on our bloggers because i'd
known about our bloggers for a long time
and i thought that it would be a really
good um
way to get started just because data vis
equals instant gratification you're able
to create something and if you're a
visual learner you're able to get a
result right away whether it's a chart
or whether it's one of the beautiful
visualizations that i looked at um
on our bloggers and it was just you know
you can you start with graphs and then
you start
really
kind of getting comfortable with the
syntax and that's what
i
really
that's what pushed me forward um
and then i also
was looking at w3schools for a variety
of different things um
it's not my favorite for r but it is
really good for sql um
and i mean
though i do written tutorials i've
thought about going back and making
videos talking through my tutorials um
my favorite uh
video blogger on our is julia
she makes the best videos and i'm not
even a video person but if i really
really need to understand something and
i need somebody to talk at me that is
where i go
um
i think also
and this is a really important point
if you want to learn another language
but you're too lazy to pull up that
interface which is something that i deal
with all the time
um you can create that environment um a
light version of that environment in r
and that's something that i definitely
want to go back and do tons of tutorials
on the sql packages in r um
especially the tensorflow and paris
packages that allow you to import um
really anything from python that you
need into the r environment because it's
very very
hard for me personally to switch back
and forth in between platforms even if i
know
um languages
but it was especially especially um
useful when i started having to do front
and work a little bit at the police
department
um
i was trying to update their
uh
base of social network graphs of which
criminals know each other basically and
i was trying to do that by using json
and javascript
um and then i noticed that the d3
package is so robust in javascript and
it was overwhelming to me but there was
a package in r that i could play with um
and that made a huge difference so
i don't i i don't
recommend like just learning the package
for sql or python and r i think that
knowing um
a lot of different languages is
important and especially you know
playing on jupiter notebooks and trying
out my sequel and trying out my sequel
with tableau i mean these are all good
things but
for
teaching a class say which i have done
i've guest lectured um
on doing housing regressions in
r
but using tensorflow and keras
then it's really cool to be able to
integrate everything you need into the
platform that you like the most um
and so
you you can
decide which environment you like the
best and just
you know research um
ways to
combine different languages into that
and that's something that i hope to have
more on my site in the future
um and i'm hoping that i can get better
at databasing through that
um
and then really i just want to say this
is just a taste um
i know that imposter syndrome is real
and when i first started doing tutorials
i thought wow literally everybody i know
is better at r than i am i felt and
that's still probably the case i mean
all of you are experts
in you know your own
um
space within the r universe and i'm a
media person i have a bird's eye view on
all of you um i've interviewed a lot of
you on my podcast data fem
and
my job is to stay knowledgeable enough
that i can um
you know provide
i guess updates on the industry um and
really tell you what your peers are
working on if you didn't know
um so
i
wanted to start doing tutorials just
because what i noticed was a
um kind of empty
space
in the tutorials i saw already is that
um
there weren't really any kind of
lifestyle blog style type blogs that had
tutorials on art like our bloggers is
amazing but it's pithy and it's very um
it's done in the tones that we're used
to hearing from tutorials
and what i wanted to do is shorten up
those tutorials make it casual
um make it a friendly conversation
um and just really draw people into
uh
learning to code by appealing to
their senses whether it's food whether
it's hobbies whether it's true crime
whether it's a fad um
and because i used to have more of a
personal blog i really wanted to combine
that style with the knowledge i had and
what i realized was that it's really not
as hard as you think to relay
information especially because there are
so many tutorials out there so
instead of
being
overwhelmed by the amount of people who
know more than you
um i would take that as a blessing and
think about
what
you can contribute that's not already
there and for me
it's just like a little bit of sass and
sarcasm and
you know hoping to bring people that
never really have tried r
into the space by doing a few quick
commands you know and
um learning that way
so
um that kind of is
most of what i had to say
um i
i know that i can sometimes ramble and i
didn't have slides because i wanted to
show you around
um
i guess
the one other thing i want to talk about
is
how i'm integrating um
more tutorials
into datafem by bringing in experts that
can do slides and
speak to it better than i can
and that also gives an opportunity for
companies to sponsor
and really get
behind
datafem as an
educational resource so the one that i
did
most recently um was an episode about
the cloud
and
it was one of my good friends chris on
twitter
who um
ended up
being the teacher in this aspect and
really the reason that it started is
because i sent a tweet out to
our twitter that i'm very active on and
i said um
that
i
don't understand the cloud as well as i
want to and he responded and he said
well you know i can teach you or like i
can you know walk you through it and i
was like well how about you walk my
audience through it
so
um that's something that i
would love you to check out um just as a
last resource and you know
any other topics that you want to hear
about feel free to reach out to me
on this site
and
you can definitely
you can definitely suggest
any topics whether it's cyber security
automation so i definitely want to
integrate um the tutorials that i do
written wise and make that more part of
data fem which is the center of my
business
so
yeah i want to say thank you and thank
you for
listening to my story and i hope that
it was helpful um to see kind of how i
fell into this space and i hope that you
all think about um
just how you can contribute to creating
content around r
great thank you very much and i want to
say i'm sorry about your walk on song i
was downloading a bunch of songs last
night and i actually had to do yours two
or three times and the first time i got
beyonce then the next times i somehow
got a lullaby so sorry about that uh
hopefully i will be able to uh get
everyone else's songs correct
so folks before we go to our first break
we're going to do a few giveaways